you have been watching perhaps one of
the most disgraceful performances by an
American president at a summit in front
of a Russian leader showing that I've
ever seen Putin has recruited
psychologically the President of the
United States I have never seen an
American president simply surrender to
the leader of Russia you should call
this the surrender summit when do we see
almost a shadow government come out and
say we cannot side with the government
whether it's the cabinet or the Senate I
think that's the big question well not
all the dumb people let's keep it's like
the question we ask every night more so
today than maybe before you know it's
certainly in a long time the reaction in
the press to the summit today was so
over the top that it was awe-inspiring
but the reaction of politicians was even
more so Chuck Schumer who holds elected
office the United States Senate
suggested that Vladimir Putin is
literally blackmailing the president
United States he did not probably
provide evidence for that charge Nancy
Pelosi in the house went even further
she said that today was ironclad proof
that Russia has something on President
Trump wasn't a lot of reasoned discourse
going on today to put him on Lee Tammy
Bruce is a reasoned person she's a radio
show host in New York a friend of this
show and she joins us tonight Tammy what
do you make of this you know it's
fascinating look in president Trump's
press conference there's something we
all didn't like necessarily but the
reaction the overreaction is
extraordinary keep in mind these are the
people who said that the tax cuts were
going to cause Armageddon that net the
end of net neutrality was going to
literally kill people that President
Trump meeting with North Korea was going
to cause World War 3 and now we've got
this a press conference after a
four-hour meeting is supposedly treason
or at least as you've noted from a
Congress member should require a
military coup the American people at
this point know something and that is
with all the work he's done so far with
whatever disagreements you may have with
President Trump he loves this country
and he is working for this country and
that is clear so when you see this kind
of hysterical reaction multiplied it
worries the American people and if their
reaction is supposedly about national
security and this
how the nation is viewed how is this
country viewed when you do have elected
officials suggesting a coup e they're
free a shadow government or through the
military or or denigrating the president
so publicly if that was the concern my
point is is that this of course is
politics it's not about national
security but they seem to mean it I mean
they seem desperate to force me to
believe it's basically a Russia agnostic
I have no interest in going to Russia
I'm not interested in Russia but they've
tried to force me to believe that Russia
is the worst country in the world the
greatest threat to my Liberty the
greatest threat to the United States of
America well that's just stupid like
anyone who pays any attention knows
that's not true you know why it's not a
defense of Russia but it's just not her
you know China's a much bigger threat so
why are they trying to force me to
believe that and punish me if I don't
nod in agreement I don't understand
because that was their first premise
they've based everything on Russia
controlling Donald Trump that was their
premise for the first six months was to
get him either to resign or to get him
impeached and look the Russians we agree
we know did metal and we know that
there's like that that that that theme
of a basic reality that Obama did
nothing about issued stand-down orders
to Susan Rice we know that through
congressional testimony and so we know
that that's occurred the president it
tends to bring the two together which is
this unfair witch-hunt versus the actual
dynamic of meddling in this country
which by the way right it really had no
no impact that's clear but but in the
meantime the Democrat Party the the
never Trump errs the establishment
invested in this fantasy of the
president Donald Trump being controlled
by the Russians which of course is
absurd in his performance over the last
over 500 days has proven his commitment
to this nation so they this is their
only investment this is what they have
and they clearly are indicating the
level of their panic and and need for
for this to be the case and the American
people have rejected it before and I
think they'll reject it again it seems a
little disproportionate to be totally
honest to put it mildly
so also during his press conference a
the president raised once again the
matter of the DNC's email server which
were told was hacked by Russia were
required to believe that
but for some reason it was never turned
over to the FBI here's part of what the
president said you have groups that are
wondering why the FBI never took the
server and haven't they taken the server
why was the FBI told to leave the office
of the Democratic National Committee
I've been wondering that up and asking
that for a months and months and I've
been tweeting it out and calling it out
on social media where is the server I
want to know where is the server and
what is the server saying with that
being said all I can do is ask the
question meanwhile Hillary Clinton made
another appearance to remind the world
that she ought to be present yesterday
she tweeted this great world cup
question for President Trump as he meets
Putin do you know which team you play
for so I just I'm interested Tammy in
this question of the server I wouldn't
be shocked if Russia tampered with it
they've been tampering and causing
mischief in this country for a hundred
years so Elliot we're not surprised me
but why is it considered unpatriotic to
ask basic questions like well where's
the server did you look at it why didn't
the FBI look at it can you answer my
basic questions why am I not allowed to
ask those questions I'm working for
Putin if I do I don't have a right as an
American citizen to get straight answers
to simple questions yeah look it
technically actually we believe the
server may have been disk emission
decommissioned and actually taken apart
this is news from April of this year and
and a filing from the DNC that they were
required to decommission or remove
software and and take apart about a
hundred and forty servers 180 computers
and 11 separate servers so it may
actually not even exist at this point
but for the President and I think that
this is key the Americans know that he
loves the country they know that that's
hogwash what they're hearing from the
media today but the president I think
would I think help put this kind of
situation to bed if you will by
addressing the fact that yes there is
meddling and that what's happening here
on the political end is very different
and has nothing to do with the fact that
he won this election fair and square but
that there are questions that we have to
ask about the politics that have invaded
this the Peter struck testimony from the
other day from yesterday shocking and
and I think that this is where the
American people deserve answers
but I just want look I just want my
specific questions answers one that I
say oh they hacked or they tampered I
believe that completely but tell me what
that means
why do you be very specific about nobody
will oh you're working for Putin when
people won't be specific two simple
questions you know there's deceit that's
my view every president's gonna hear
these complaints and I think so will the
FBI I hope so
yeah great to see you